in his part of the future because next
to love art was in the other idea of
Wagner to create a better world in art
of the future Wagner writes art despite
its noble intentions has zero impact on
public life there was 150 years ago if
it was zero there now it's far below
zero why the loss of impact of Arts in
our society why is it that the Opera
House concert houses nexuses should we
all are struggling to keep a world of
art alive and it's it's a tough fight
yeah what why why is heart no longer
considered to be because at least in a
time of Nietzsche evac'd and that was
another argument they all believed that
art or a form of art is the important
thing because art is born as from from
and from an elite and there's no you
can't deny that it is it is created by
an elite and it is it is ultimately
appreciated by an elite and then and it
has a further life which one would have
hoped in the age of the internet would
have flourished and abolished your
worries but what is happening which is
tragic is that it's had the opposite
effect instead of by now what we should
be in a situation where art is is really
flourishing is really communicating is
really creating new audiences in a
normal way because the Internet is a
free is a free highway in which the
ideas you can see things you can hear
things you can you can distribute things
but it doesn't seem to be working like
that and it's very tragic and very
worrying and nothing that could be the
topic of a whole conference here
actually because I look at like band
camp where any band can put their music
on the Internet
or say in Korea webtoons you have
several million Koreans subscribing to
two web comics which are appreciated by
mostly teenagers for people of all ages
it seems like there's an incredible
flourishing of art being created and
distributed online I mean it may not be
the kind of art that you personally
produce it is a transformation it's it's
going in another direction but I think
the I mean here you're organizing a
conference around the ring which is
sophisticated one of the one of the
great monuments of world culture it's
it's really difficult to beat the ring
in next hundred years from any artist
creating something like that you you
would like that to be created in the
next comment that you would like to
imagine that another partner is born
that that that another type of ring is
also created to in a way to update a
little bit the journey of 200 years that
would have happened
I'm brother pessimistic about it because
I think the the the the ring is a very
very very complex work it has many many
music illogical layers of tremendous
genius it's not just the the ideas that
we are debating today about the
characters and so on that are already
extraordinary it's the music it's the
way it's put together it's a
conversational piece from beginning to
end it's one one huge conversational
piece of you know 12 hours it's it's
it's extraordinary it's all conversation
it's all people it's it's it's it's an
extraordinary creation on a musical
level and a large part of what it says
is in the music in the orchestral
material or not in the words so there
are you know multiple layers of
communication with the audience or the
listener it's interesting to also just
listen
and watch but you can approach it from
many many many angles and I think this
kind of I'm just trying to prove that
this is a very sophisticated work and to
you would hope that you could actually
communicate this richness and acquire
new followers but that's not what the
Internet is interested in I want to
agree with Ben for just for the sheer
pleasure of it for a moment which is I
think you're right
there is popular music and popular
culture that is not kitsch that there
are genuine human emotions in meat in
popular music and film for example and
so having said that I think that vogner
was wrong in what you read in other
words insofar as he was arguing that art
is non-utilitarian it's easy to agree
with him but I think that insofar as
empathy is the basis of ethical action
and imagination is the basis of empathy
that is to say insofar as with without
the imagination we could only picture
sufferings that we ourselves have
suffered and our compassion would be
extremely limited especially us upper
you know middle-class bourgeois types
who you know recently experienced a
toothache
right so I think that an art it is art
precisely art at all its levels that
presents that puts before people a much
wider range of human experience than
they could ever gather on their own so
you know at the highest level there are
the plays of Shakespeare there's vogner
there's Verdi at the middle level and
high level they're the novels of Dickens
there's the cinema they're I mean and
all of these things basically enlarge
the imagination and insofar as they
enlarge the imagination they are if
you'll pardon the expression socially
useful because they make compassion
possible that Vagner may have been wrong
it is possible Rob that you are wrong
in the premise of your question I am not
really convinced that art today is any
less important than it was in Inverness
time I knew you stage drink and they
come they come for many years you think
and they come why do you think and and
we are moved by it it is not just
weekend because they are enough to fill
a very large in terms of the book
industry which is my industry never have
so many young people walked into so many
bookstores when we thought that the
digital book was winning it didn't we
you have paper books the paper so the
person who founded iTunes two years ago
in London told me that the book business
today is worth more than television and
music meaning rock but together even if
that figure is slightly off it is still
extraordinary that the book business is
thriving people are watching series not
all of them stupid so it is
extraordinary and it's true that in the
beginning and in its transform and it's
true in the beginning it was elitist to
read novels are only bourgeois could do
it or bourgeois maybe women or people
who weren't occupied but today it's
becoming less and less so more people
are reading across the social spectrum
it's extraordinary to sit in the subway
at times even in the times of iPhones
you have people reading constantly paper
books on on airplanes all kinds of books
sometimes you know not so highbrow and
sometimes quite really extraordinary
books are being read all over the world
and I Umberto Eco and I interviewed him
for the Paris Review told me this he
said I don't think I told him I said you
think ultras die he said not at all
it's it's thriving and I agree with you
with the internet and different forms
it's not just transforming but old forms
are also becoming more available and we
have gern a new generation of young
people who is extremely interested in
art and convenience Rob is right about
one thing
[Applause]